and you are dressed up in a way where
you were hypersexualized you are nothing
but a sexual object and you have the
audacity to tell a Muslim woman that she
is brainwashed it just blows my mind bro
welcome to Black resin where we redefine
skincare try our squeaky clean test
promise for radiant skin our exclusive
resin formula repairs exfoliates and
hydrates get that refreshing glow also
available as a face wash elevate your
skincare with black resin your skin
deserves the best use weekly for best
results Link in the description box
we are going to be reacting to the
Jubilee nice Queen's Jubilee no she's
dead now oh that's not nice yeah this is
different Jubilee nice so I've been
meaning to react to this but
alhamdulillah today we're going to be
doing that and it really really
triggered me and it's very funny enough
to bring back these ex-muslims the
absolute waste of spaces they're trying
to trigger you that's why people exactly
we're like they're just so this is
boring now we've gone past that that was
like 10 years ago your hype is gone
you're finished no one gives a damn yeah
please anyways let's watch this so This
Woman here really triggered me yeah um
are you ready I'm ready to get triggered
let's see here is the question I think
brainwash is a strong word but I also
obviously step forward I was raised
Muslim I'm Iranian my mom's side of the
family especially a lot of Iranians they
felt like they just had to become Muslim
to obviously like adhere and it's
extreme what they're doing or not
obviously I'm not comparing but I guess
with brainwash I also went to an Islamic
school so my really develop Muslim
friends it feels like brainwashed I have
a friend who's hijabi and I just like
for her it feels like it wasn't a choice
kind of vibe it's just something you
should do because of your family because
religion but then she's also super
devout Muslim it's just a hairy topic
we're going to go to a couple of videos
where she talks yeah but in a nutshell
here I find it so ironic I find it so
bizarre that the Western woman when I
first watched this obviously I saw a
glimpse of her and in that Glimpse I
realized that she's wearing a mini skirt
she's got her chest out and I'm like wow
the audacity I mean the fact that you
think you are not brainwashed and for
you to think that basically her idea is
what this is freedom you're oppressed
yeah and I'm thinking and I've had a
discussion with many people before the
Western woman you are so damn deluded
that in the nightclubs I used to go in
jahiliya you would be called a hoe and
guess what you would be dancing to it
and repeating and saying I'm a hoe I
mean if that is not brainwashing to a
level where you are accused of being
somebody who is promiscuous and sleeps
around and you can proudly come and say
I am yeah I'm a hoe I'm a bad b-i-t-c-h
and you are dressed up in a way where
you are hypersexualized you are nothing
but a sexual object and you have the
audacity to tell a Muslim woman that she
is brainwashed it just blows my mind bro
a lot of her statements was somebody
went to a madressa I feel they're
brainwashed what a dead statement just
because you feel they're brainwashed
doesn't make them brainwashed and she
undercut everything when she said yeah I
think it's a bit of a strong term but a
step forward if you think it's a strong
term don't step forward you know what I
mean so and the other thing is like like
you said being influenced I when you go
to a certain school look you're always
gonna be influenced you're always going
to be it's a synonym isn't it of
brainwashing either you're going to be
brainwashed by the secular liberals or
you're going to be brainwashed by the
knowledge that comes from the Creator I
don't know about you but I don't want
some guys in suits who just care about
making more profit and money and
individual and are focused about
individualism and a Godless I don't want
these people frankly giving me ideals
and giving me lessons of morality
frankly I think too like dressing about
the Quran in my upbringing like I had
every day the two biggest ones that come
out stand out to me would be like the
issue of the hijab which I know a lot of
people will counter so the Quran says
women have to cover the heimar to cover
up so that they don't tempt um the men
and then I will say the Quran does
technically say men's hijab is their
gaze the male gaze and I just that just
seems a little silly to me beyond that
like in the Quran how men can have up to
four wives but women can't it's like I
or I in the Islamic school I want to say
the Azan the call to prayer all the boys
in my class they're like we're gonna do
the call to prayer for this Friday I'm
ineligible because I'm a woman
apparently can't do liaison I can't do
the call to prayer so just those I would
say are my core on specific examples and
they're like well this is to protect
women I don't see that at all I mean I
mean the brothers did an amazing job how
perfect can you be you know yeah so for
example she said for example nowhere in
the Quran does Allah say that woman
should cover up because men can't
control theirself and number two know
what does it say a man's hijab is only
the role in the gates that's not okay
because Allah believe in men and the
believing women to lower their case and
of course for a man it's obviously with
us for visual creatures um so that's
that's that and then she talks about
polygamy for that matter there's many
reasons why not every man is believing
is by nature yes and you think you know
do you think the Western man is not you
feel the Western man doesn't go around
have side chicks missions and
girlfriends to sleep around you know
even I heard in France it's in their
cultures have a mistress you know and uh
and she's talking about that and then oh
I couldn't do that then I can well I can
turn around and say you know what why
why am I obligated to pray um you know
highly obligated to pray in the mosque
but my wife isn't she has the same
reward why I don't need to go to your
mother but she doesn't why am I the
protection provider but she's not I mean
what's so pathetic yeah the thing is
that look when when you acknowledge that
there is a Creator yeah the argument has
to stem with do you believe that there
is a God or do you believe that there is
no God if you don't believe that there
is a God naturally your morality is
coming from some something else so who
are you to judge someone else's morality
so if Allah created us which we believe
that he did his law is all-encompassing
so if he in his Divine wisdom knowing us
knowing everything he says that okay men
are doing this women are doing that I'm
sorry it's not even if I uh no it's not
up for you know discussion you know I
mean it's not something that okay we
accept God is all knowing he knows
everything he sees everything and he's
you know created all of this and we're
gonna decide what right is what wrong is
and we're gonna decide what's in his
book what's not in his book and what's
right what's wrong how presumptuous of
you how arrogant of you particularly if
you look at yourself look at the way
you're dressed you can dress up like
minus your cleavage is showing and
you're telling me that you chose to
really did you really wake up and all
these women that are affected by the
hypersexualized society and the beauty
industry and the botox industry and the
the surgeons that they're going under
that some of them even lose their life
they become Martyrs yes one woman in
Brazil because you've got button plans
she became a martyr at the course and my
favorite book Beauty sick I would
recommend you to buy it as well very
simple yeah literally but that's what it
is when it comes to God's Commandments
he said who you are no you can't tell me
what to do but you are the same person
that follows this liberal secular World
View to a point where you don't even
question it you telling me when you wake
up and had to do makeup you can't live
without makeup the fact that you have to
wear a mini skirt the question is why do
you find the need to show your legs I'm
just curious now you can do whatever you
like I'm just curious why did you find
the need to show your breasts I'm very
curious what trick is you to be like I
would like to present myself in this
manner you think you choose no you don't
Allah says in the Quran have you seen
the one who has one master compared to
three Masters or Moto Masters the one
who has one master which you talked
about is God we we follow his regulation
you have multiple Masters your friends
opposite gender the beauty industry so
many other factors that the society
societal pressures that is telling you
how to look how to be what to eat what
size waist you should be what size your
face should be how big is your fish
should be how big you know should be to
the level that if I was to come here and
question your looks if I come and sit
you for example you know your nose yeah
it looks it looks a bit big that comment
in itself I bet she's watching this and
be like you know what my nose I'm just
saying no you're always going to be
questioning exactly exactly exactly does
it and even me the fact I'm mentioning
this the fact that you're insecure this
is what the Western system has done to
you make you feel so ugly now you're
gonna be thinking maybe I should get no
surgery you are a slave and a byproduct
of your Society always saying to you is
our sister that come and worship the
true God because he knows what's best
for you and it's as simple as that even
when you say um I'm picking my clothing
before there used to be three seasons in
fashion yes now there's something that's
come out it's called Fast fashion yes
and there's only like three or four
shops and it's a new fashion season
every week frankly and one thing that I
don't get whenever these people talk
about Freedom why is it always removing
clothes why does no woman ever go you
know what is a freedom my body my choice
I'm gonna put on more clothes I want to
cover my hair more exactly exactly why
that why is that not the case everywhere
you go why isn't that these women choose
Freedom by covering up why why is it in
these countries they always like France
a secular liberal country why is it that
they're banning putting on clothes
rather than taking off clothes exactly
because because it's a choice it's a
state's Choice that's the problem